The joe rogan experience.
The weirdest thing though is that in the
audience I have is so bizarre because
that guy will be there.
There will be a guy there,
a Panthera guy,
there'll be a guy there,
was there last summer I did,
you know an acoustic run of,
oh and I did one.
I'm doing a few festivals.
I show up at one and I
shit you not Joe Rogan,
it's called devil slide or or devil side,
devil side festival.
It is nothing but the hardest.
Like,
Oh,
I'm sitting backstage with me and Brian,
the guy who came with me last time
keyboard player and we're like,
what the fuck man,
this just,
why am I here?
I don't even fucking get him
and were like freaking out.
We're like,
oh,
they're going to fucking kill us man.
They're going to kill us.
I called my manager,
I'm cursing him to high fucking heaven,
Dude.
Like you motherfucker.
You don't even look
where you're booking me,
do you?
You just see a check number and you
take it and you don't even ask where you
just say,
yeah,
we'll do it.
Huh?
I was like,
I listen to where I am and I'm putting the
band after band of it,
man,
I'm,
I'm actually to get to the point where
it's like I just started embracing that
funniness of it not to live promoters.
All right.
There's some things missing from my rider.
And they're like,
what?
I'm like,
I need to say Tannic Bible in a
bucket of goat's blood right now.
I was like,
we need to make a sacrifice for we go
out there cause we about to get killed.
And it was,
it was the craziest shit it up.
So,
uh,
I fucking with me,
I tell my boy,
and it wasn't Brian Actually,
it was my boy Derek.
We were both playing two guitars.
So,
uh,
we go,
I go and I just tell
him when we got there,
I was like,
first thing to get thrown first,
anything.
We're fucking up,
I'm out of there.
And they fucking,
someone jumps on stage and
just hit him with the guitar,
man.
It's like dead ass.
I'm saying this dead seriously.
Like we're about to get killed,
right.
So this band that went on before us,
it was like the bread that gets
buttered with bread or something.
It was,
that's literally,
it was some crazy name like that on the
bread gets buttered or the butter on the
bread or something like that.
And it was the most artists like craziest,
craziest,
it ends and the lights and,
and this is the middle of
the day by the way too.
This is like four o'clock maybe
five o'clock and we're like,
ah man,
Jesus done come.
The whole house clears.
So like all of a sudden I'm
having a little bit of hope,
like okay,
maybe nobody will just be in here for
our said maybe they all just were like
that.
No,
we're going to go get a beer.
So they are changing over
the set and come to our turn.
And I'm like,
the crowd starts coming
back in and I'm like,
man,
this ugly.
Go out there and we start playing
our guitars and next thing I know,
I see all of these pants,
Tara and crazy metal dudes
and they got chicks with them.
Now.
There's not,
there's not a pit.
There's not a pit,
there's not pit.
There's all these dudes with their
broad and they're holding their bras and
they're listening and they're,
and it goes over like fucking gangbusters.
I was like,
we and we,
we literally got offstage dump.
We didn't say words to each other.
We got in our van,
we didn't even set up merchant
this place because we were like,
nobody cares where here we sold like
probably I a box of merchant out the back
of the van when people
catching us cause we were just,
I mean me and Derek was sitting in
the back of the van just like the,
that just happened.
Man,
that was,
that was one of the craziest
gigs I've ever done in my life.
That's fascinating that they just changed
gears like that and it was no other
thing like that.
It was,
it was,
it was.
I never,
I was just blown away about how it went
and in the way it went over I was like,
wow dude,
that was crazy.
They really dug it.
That's a cool story.
That must have been a cool experience.
So my audience is crazy.
It'll be an old lady.
There'll be like kids,
there'll be,
you know,
the house of pain.
You know,
a rough neck hooligan.
Guy's still hanging on
for that to come back.
Okay.